the pain at the pump becoming such a
hard reality for many valley businesses
joe moeller spoke with some people who
say it's really impacting their bottom
line joe
i'm sure you both have noticed that 10
or 20 and 30 bucks does not go as far at
the pump as it used to a couple months
ago here's a live look at sahara and
maryland parkway 409 here last week it
was 405. now people who have to fill up
their tank for work say this is hitting
them hard
it's brutal if you were in the business
of transporting products the problem we
have is getting our product inbound
chances are you are paying more like
greenfield and company wholesale flowers
near the strip over the last two months
we've seen fuel prices go up
per kilo on air air freight every week
they import flowers from around the
world distribute flowers to nearby
states and sell to small shops and even
resorts bruce greenfield says with gas
on the rise importing and delivery costs
have gone up forcing them to make
changes it forced us to really shop
better from our farms and try to work
better deals with them
to offset the expense of freight he says
they don't want to increase flower
prices unless absolutely necessary we
don't want our customers coming in and
feeling well what's it going to cost
today for people making a living
transporting people the costs are
hitting them hard gas prices are up
they're almost five bucks a gallon
daniel brown is a private driver and
rideshare driver he fills up every other
day they haven't adjusted
the fair prices to
our gas prices at the end of the day he
takes us home tip your drivers cash is
better as he and greenfield try and
navigate the costs they hope relief
comes soon it's just going to happen
until things get settled down and
changes are made
now back out here live it was 409 here
other places around the strip we saw
4.15 cents even for 17. now greenfield
says he'll be keeping a close eye on
what's happening in ukraine to see how
it will reflect at the pump reporting
live joe mulder live local now